oh let me shout out this lady on Tick
Tock her name is culture work I've only
ever seen her kind of breaking down
funny PR stunts she had a funny Tech
talk where she's breaking down the whole
emrata Pete Davidson TMZ League she's
like look how [ __ ] fake this is and
she's kind of stepping through and I'm
like oh yeah this is like a fake
relationship yeah oh okay yeah so
basically she kind of points out that
this whole maybe just look up emirata
Pete Davidson Paparazzi on YouTube
because her commentary was dude look how
look how step by step this [ __ ] is
and there's so clearly emrata trying to
get cues from whoever is filming
and I don't watch I hate PR [ __ ] like
this I know because I [ __ ] fell for
it like I saw that and every part of me
was like oh man that's crazy bro and I
didn't care that much but I was like man
that is crazy happy Davidson really does
is that's crazy that that's that's all
good PR is it's just subtle suggestion I
know but it's it's like it makes me feel
like a [ __ ] chump
let's just like hug for a video and like
plant some [ __ ] where there's because
someone looks through a doorway and sees
us hug yeah everyone's gonna go [ __ ]
nuts it's like they just see we're not
people it's just like yeah you're
animals we're just manipulating yeah
you're all stupid things yeah you're
stupid that's what they think of you
I hate it you know what else sorry this
is a weird tangent off this but so I
went and voted last week
and just yeah I I'm a [ __ ] hero
uh sorry I went and voted last week
and that's still wearing the sticker
right here that's the episode that's it
I did it no no I I went and did it and I
was sort of laughing at the ballot
because it's so long there's so many
people
I'm trying to research everybody as much
as possible and you know and then I'm
like God it
to do proper research for this
it it would take time so I understand
how voting Works in terms of
you have people that just vote the party
line
and whatever whatever but I have ever
I'm not pointing anything out that's new
which is like a lot of winning campaigns
just getting those people in the middle
to go one way or the other yeah I
laughed at all the prop measures when
you look at the marketing budget behind
them that's that's who wins yeah yeah
like there I forgot what profit was but
it was like the funding was like 2
million to 200 000. yeah and when you go
look at the votes it's like well yeah
yeah and they're just putting out it
also made me laugh at those [ __ ]
cornerly edited
prop things or like vote no on Prop
seven it'll turn yeah yeah they do
that's what this [ __ ] is it's okay okay
so start from the top she's basically
pointing out how when the paparazzi
starts kind of how the camera arrives to
this moment is super contrived
God damn it can we just [ __ ] yeah so
it's like Pete is sort of like supposed
to be like covering his face and then
watch her reaction here it's like she's
waiting for the [ __ ] camera and then
she moves
and then she does this awkward between
the cars like looking to the paparazzi
and then her body language is super
whatever here
this whole thing this just feels
his favorite part
bruh
they like they weren't thinking like
they didn't think about the [ __ ]
glass door that they just walked through
a giant window on it yeah that's the
point
yeah
that's what she's pointing out she's
like dude this is
C tier
yeah let me say this Indian because I'm
dumb and I [ __ ] the first time I saw
that I was like that's crazy let me tell
you something Indian teenagers Indian
teenagers make more believable stories
on Tick Tock with a ton of [ __ ]
built-in special effects and cap cut
yeah then and that [ __ ] right there dude
there should be like rules against this
you know what I'm saying just like there
are like rules of marketing
what rules what rules what rules I
thought men were important
like just like there's just like when
you post something on Instagram you and
you're promoting something you have to
put hashtag ad yes they're like this is
for Consumer Protection why isn't there
[ __ ] consumer protection for fake PR
[ __ ] like that for relationships I don't
know how you do that
you have to disclaim
uh is there a governing body that yeah
yo I'm so happy to be partnering up with
emrata uh yeah yeah yeah okay David's
Vanessa oh yeah yeah public I'm really
happy I'm really happy happy we've
partnered up with each other yeah yeah
wow public relate dudes so
it's all it's almost like marriage we
tell the government right but
uh it's like different yeah so you
legally have to declare we are [ __ ]
if it's fake oh oh you think they're
actually [ __ ] no no I don't I thought
that's what you were saying I thought
there needs to be some no no it has to
be like they're faking it right but they
have to disclose that they're faking
there just needs to be the hashtag ad
for public relations yeah or hashtag you
know so happy to partner partner with
emrata yeah for this or whatever you
know has to be disclosed to us in some
way
yeah I don't think so man
that rules what rules
you got guys like Pete Davidson
teaching men that all you do you deep
around there's no honor in that
he's not even [ __ ] emrata
learn a skill
learn a trade
he's not even [ __ ] her
he's duping you you've been drooped
what dupe
yeah dude
he's [ __ ] her what [ __ ]
what [ __ ] have we seen
just because we say then we [ __ ] that
that's not how we work yeah yeah
you're making many assumptions even when
you say that
what is [ __ ]
and that's not cool that's not to say
that we have to to see it for it to be
real but there should be something
substantive about the [ __ ] what is [ __ ]
there's a lot okay to okay but then you
say [ __ ] is two people bumping
fuzzies but I would say
what are people
what are fuzzies
you make a lot of assumptions in a
sentence like that
what is a penis
can a penis be fuzzy
you assume everyone has pubes
how do we account for those with no Pew
Jordan shut the [ __ ] up Jordan
I'm just showing you this TMZ video I
thought it was kind of crazy you're
ruining the vibe dude
is it not crazy Pete Davidson I mean
he's like every girl in Hollywood I just
cannot believe that they're actually
[ __ ] that's what I'm saying
Jordan thank you bro
nice to see you back on Twitter by the
way
I'm back
thanks Elon no one said no one making
mean comments about me not liking girls
foreign
to get bullied off again dude